good nominees for Best Original Song are
from The Triplets of Belleville L will
rendezvous music by Benoit char a lyric
by a silver shield man from the Lord of
the Rings The Return of the King into
the West music and lyric by Fran Walsh
Howard Shore and Annie Lennox from a
mighty wind a kiss at the end of the
rainbow music and lyrics by Michael
McKean
and Annette O'Toole from Cold Mountain
scarlet tide music and lyric by t-bone
Burnett and Elvis Costello
from home mountain you will be my aim
true love music and lyric by state and
they asked and the Oscar goes to Fran
Walsh Howard Shore and Annie Lennox her
into the West from the Lord of the Rings
The Return of the King
this is the first Academy Award for Fran
Walsh and Annie Lennox mrs. Howard
Shores third Oscar he won previously for
the Lord of the Rings the Fellowship of
the Ring and earlier tonight for
Original Score
Wow I'm stunned thank you so very much
to the Academy I'd like to thank Peter
Jackson so much for inviting me to be
part of this extraordinary project thank
you so much Peter it's amazing thank you
Fran hard she's very moving for me you
were extraordinary very inspiring and I
hope you enjoyed the song when I sang it
tonight Thank You Simon my wonderful
manager Tara my assistant Joyce at home
I'd like to dedicate to my performance
of the song to my my brother who passed
away last year
and also to my darling friend Michael
Kaman I'll miss them so much
thank you
can I do one thing I would I just want
to do one think tiny thank you and it's
to Sharon and Rhys tank and who are
watching in New Zealand and there's some
I know more but this one was an
inspiration for this song and it's an
honor to share it with him thank you
you